[MUSIC PLAYING]
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
What we have today
is a ton of different agencies
here all focusing on mobile,
and they're here to learn
from one another as well
as the experts that
we've got in the room.
So you'll see that we cover
a wide range of topics.
WM LELER: We are looking
for agencies to build apps
with our new product.
One-on-one conversations
with people work really well.
If that's all we
had done all day,
that would have been
worth the whole day.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD: We
need to get agencies
learning from one another.
And so what we've done
here is split them
out into lots of different
groups, CXOs and founders
in one corner talking
about the kind of issues
that are important to them.
We've also got developers
in another corner talking
about the issues that are most
important to them as well.
MARK THOMAS: It was kind
of like group mentoring.
It was interesting to
get different opinions,
similar problems.
I look to follow the
discussions after this event.
STEFAN GERSTMEIER: To
liase with other agencies,
to learn from their experience,
having access to the Google
experts here like the UX
Review, helps us a lot.
PRAMADA SAHU: I'm
looking forward
to interact with
people, to network,
to understand how we can become
a certified Google agency.
ALEX CARNESSA: I like
this approach where
the coffee break has more time.
First, because I'm Italian
and I love coffee, second,
because I really like this part
of the program where agencies
meet each other.
So I'm looking forward to
meet other people, actually.
ROSALIE HARAN: We talked
about different tools
that we're using,
challenges of working
with remote teams
who might be getting
a little fatigued and bored.
ANTHONY GALVIN:
When we do well is
when we do something
that's new and exciting,
and working with a
company like Google
gives us loads of opportunity
to do new, interesting things.
RUPERT WHITEHEAD:
It's really nice
to see people who
would otherwise
be competing with one
another sitting down together
and learning from one another.
When agencies partner
together and learn together,
they have so much more
that they can gain than
by going it alone.
WM LELER: Can you tell
I'm happy about this?
You know, it's like [LAUGHS]